welcome to this video playing against
grandma's orantium this is I think golf
kufstein right leonid gustine leon
gosselin yeah very good Grandmaster of
Israel I think we rarely plays over the
board chest nowadays small active as a
trainer and occasionally place here on a
sec okay so the Kings Indian with them
seven Bishop e3 the glicca rich
variation ah i will notice displayed
night h61 move it's also gt5 I really
forgot it
I think this is playable the non-id form
maybe I'm confusing things they're
probably i do i can just take take g for
what i think i have screwed this up
already
ok
I have some were confused move orders
here okay so g4 hangs d4 hangs what what
am I supposed to do hmm
bf5 yeah this is gone terribly wrong
fine I can just take it of course
yeah the problem is if I'd go back to e5
he just takes d4 and I'm toast
mmm does some way to confuse matches no
this is probably of complete nonsense he
can play anything actually Nigel phone
or something my idea was h3h form but
yeah this isn't really working at all
yeah
maybe maybe this song gives me some
activity at least
hmm am I still alive here for some
reason I don't know Abby to wangs I mean
okay with those pawns and everything but
maybe maybe i am still halfway alive but
sir let's take this
hmm yeah what to see what towards doing
now Brooksie one on can maybe just take
a five then
hmm
Bishop takes g4 as an idea really queen
a one Queen a one Bishop a one Bishop
takes h5 if I take that on f5 he's got a
seven and the spawn promotes this is
some very viable idea maybe he's
thinking about that if he should take g4
first ok didn't happen ok Chandi I need
to do that ok but it's this too bad if i
get f five he has a hard time to protect
it anyway so maybe i should protect the
pawn him rook b7 I mean it's not the
porn it's the rock on the seventh son
I think I get get both pawns if
everything's falling into place I maybe
get both both of them our look b5 could
be an idea about half between a 10 K
would be 5 is complete nonsense hmm yes
somehow I'm not lost i don't know why
but the game continues and the danger
famous that i actually went both both
pawns not just one pawn but both of them
in the sun is some problem okay night
age 6 first you may be first why not
check oh i forgot about this check
entirely
hmm okay but that's not a CH six still I
can give the check in check
wow really you can do that why why can
you do that I didn't really check I
couldn't really believe that
I mean the thing is I have a big counter
check going it's not like he's just
meeting me or something and I take h1
and I threaten instantly Queen 81 liquid
e1 like King me three Queen takes what's
it doing the actual needs to go yes I
don't understand right here I've got
Queenie I've got Queenie one I mean this
is lovely Chang I just have Queenie one
and I making myself what the heck
queen f3s not bad as well
wow what did want to check out the game
check
don't I don't see him made Jack let's
keep it simple and make sure that I'm
not mated myself white resigned oh yeah
I was completely busted in the opening
but somehow he didn't he didn't win it
didn't oh yeah I confused actually my
mistake I think my mistake was there is
a line where after f6 white goes here
and after that this is this is in fact a
line i'm pretty sure not one hundred
percent sure but if really sure um okay
so but what I played this is complete
nonsense it's not working I think at
least the other computer doesn't doesn't
agree and now it says night h6 is so
pretty decent for black so my age 5 was
my didn't I really think about night h6
I don't know yeah it's not you have the
thing is if he takes this is quite nice
actually for black if you have just
imagined this position got some really
big bishops okay so night takes yeah
yeah somehow I'm still alive in this in
this position after h5 yeah some are in
the Kings Indian once in a while there
the awesomes games where black really
needs to be in check yeah beat more than
once it's
somehow resistance yeah be success the
computer just wants to take a five but
how can you count how should you here
can calculate it even the sketch I
didn't want the loop here so okay and
now aged 6 h 3 is this is strong check
out the computer likes that a lot for
white I'm not sure really maybe from a
technical point of view which is good
it's possible I mean white has mixed up
on ya I mean I the best i can do is get
it back but at least I'm not made of
something check this here this is just
not not working at a check he needs to
play em play Queen back here and then it
just continues I don't know I thought
maybe I can take and plane i th six but
this is probably not check not too great
yeah this is very good for what actually
yeah I was lucky marine Queenie kicking
it to a stack it's just losing the game
check yeah here that's probably a
checkmate somewhere but ok what I did
this service is completely all right
okay thanks for watching